[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
Willkommen an meiner Seite ist Norbert
Lehmann für den Sport von mir und das
sind die Nachrichten Themen von heute
mehr Tempo beim solarausbau
balkonkraftwerke sollen bald
unkomplizierte ans Netz gehen auch
landwirtschaftliche Flächen stehen im
Fokus
grünes Licht für Gras die
Bundesregierung stimmt für die Teil
Legalisierung von Cannabis Kritik kommt
nicht nur von Kindern und jugendärzten
und das WM-Finale ist komplett nach
Spanien stehen nun auch Englands
Fußballfrauen im Endspiel für Australien
Platz der Traum vom Titel im eigenen
Land
[Musik]
nach drei Wochen Sommerpause kam das
Bundeskabinett heute erstmals wieder
zusammen und hat eine ganze Reihe von
lang diskutierten Gesetzen auf den Weg
gebracht unter anderem das solarpaket
das soll die Nutzung von Solaranlagen
einfacher machen auch auf dem Balkon vor
allem durch weniger Bürokratie mehr als
230.000 dieser kleinen Kraftwerke sind
bereits registriert etwa die Hälfte
gegen in diesem Jahr in Betrieb und auch
auf den Dächern von Unternehmen und
Privathäusern boomt die Photovoltaik
2019 waren es noch 1,7 Millionen Anlagen
aktuell sind es gut 3 Millionen wie
schon
ein Balkon Kraftwerk damit kann jeder
seinen eigenen grünen Strom erzeugen die
Module Kosten ab 600 € aufwärts ab
nächstem Jahr soll der Betrieb dieser
Anlagen unkomplizierter werden durch
weniger Bürokratie
und hier sind ganz wesentliche
Voraussetzungen jetzt geschaffen worden
um es einfach zu machen kein großes
registrierungsanmeldeverfahren
Genehmigungsverfahren sondern man zeigt
es an und fertig ist die Welt geplant
ist neben der Vereinfachung der
Meldepflichten eine Erhöhung der
Maximalleistung von 600 auf 2000 Watt
und die Duldung von rückwärtsdrehenden
Zählern was Stromkosten sinken lässt
noch nicht gelöst ist die steckerfrage
bislang war ein Stecker Pflicht mit
spezieller Dose die nur vom Fachmann
eingebaut werden durfte der
wieland-stecker ausreichen soll bald der
normale Schutzkontaktstecker aber das
steht noch nicht im Gesetz Stecker hin
oder her die Nachfrage nach
balkonkraftwerken boomt weil man damit
Geld sparen kann
so ein Balkon Kraftwerk liefert bis zu
600 Watt pro Stunde damit kann ich
meinen Kühlschrank oder mein Laptop
betreiben nicht den gesamten Haushalt
noch nicht weil es technisch noch nicht
geht aber wenn man relativ hohen
Verbrauch hat und Balkon soll er Einsatz
kann man bis zu 100 € im Jahr einsparen
das ist durchaus nach Hausnummer sparen
können künftig auch alle Parteien in
Mehrfamilienhäusern jeder soll anteilig
profitieren von den minikraftwerken
trotzdem gibt es Kritik von
Umweltverbänden
für eine richtige solarpflicht auf
Neubauten und Bestandsgebäuden da wo es
Sinn macht nur dann kann man
sicherstellen dass er Solar
energieausbau diesmal kein Strohfeuer
ist das auch die doppelte Nutzung
landwirtschaftlicher Flächen möglich
machen alles für das erklärte
regierungsziel
die erneuerbaren Energien zügig
auszubauen
vor der Sommerpause war das
heizungsgesetz zum Austausch von Öl und
Gasheizungen der große Aufreger dazu gab
es heute eine wichtige Ergänzung bevor
nämlich die Eigentümer verpflichtet
werden mit umweltfreundlichen Energien
zu heizen sind die Kommunen gefragt sie
müssen einen wärmeplan erstellen auch
damit die Verbraucher wissen ob Sie Ihre
Heizung anpassen müssen
vorbildlich ist der Heidelberg Petra
Otto
eine riesige Luft Wasserwärmepumpe ein
Holzheizkraftwerk Fernwärmeleitung für
die halbe Stadt und ein 55 Meter hoher
Turm mit heißem Wasser zur Einspeisung
ins Heidelberg Musterschülerin in Sachen
ökologischer wärmeplanung die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger interessiert an
diesem Wandel die Leute fragen die
möchten wissen wie die Wärmeversorgung
in Ihrer Straße in den nächsten fünf
oder zehn Jahren aussieht weil die
natürlich auch eine Investitionsplanung
machen gegebenenfalls eine Heizung
erneuern wollen insofern braucht man
einen solchen Plan Altstadt wie
Heidelberg muss jetzt jede Kommune ein
wärmeplan erstellen ein Konzept wie wird
wo in Zukunft geheizt wie hoch ist der
Verbrauch im Viertel welche Potentiale
gibt's für erneuerbare ein Gesetz dazu
heute im Kabinett abgesegnet Deutschland
soll bis 2045 klimaneutral heizen
decarbonisiert ohne Kohle die
Karbonisierung muss mit Plan gemacht
werden damit wir das zeitlich überhaupt
schaffen bis 20-45 aber auch natürlich
auch die
bürgerplanungsorient Sicherheit haben
was Ihre Kommune vor Ort machen wird und
was nicht in großen Städten und in
kleinen Gemeinden wärmepläne
flächendeckend dass wird richtig teuer
vor allem die Umsetzung der Konzepte ich
gehe davon aus dass wir durch die
Umstellung auf eine klimaneutrale
Wärmeversorgung auch durch Investitionen
in die Gebäude wir bis zur Mitte dieses
Jahrhunderts ungefähr noch mal 300
Milliarden Euro extra ausgeben müssen
das verteilt sich aber auch viele Jahre
und es spart auch Energiekosten einer
ähnlichen Höhe ein wie die wärmewende
finanziert werden soll steht im Gesetz
nicht drin die Kommunen fordern
Unterstützung vom Bund und von den
Ländern
neben all den Beschlüssen gab es auch
Streit im Kabinett Familienministerin
Paus von den Grünen blockierte das
wachstumsschancengesetz von FDP
Finanzminister Lindner dieses Gesetz
sieht Steuerentlastungen für Unternehmen
in Höhe von 6 Milliarden Euro vor und
soll Investitionen ankurbeln Haus will
dem offenbar nur zustimmen wenn sie auch
mehr Geld für die Kinder Grundsicherung
bekommt haben wir energy in Berlin warum
stellt sich Lisa paulster quer ja die
Blockade von dieser Pause ist der
bisherige Höhepunkt einer offenen fede
muss man sagen zwischen der
Familienministerin und dem
Bundesfinanzminister beide streiten seit
Monaten über die Frage wie viel Geld in
Zeiten knapper Kassen übrig ist für die
Kindergrundsicherung und die Kinder
Grundsicherung das war am Anfang der
Ampel mal einen gemeinsames Projekt
gegen Kinderarmut mittlerweile ist es
vor allem eine Herzensangelegenheit der
Bundesfamilienministerin und der Grünen
insbesondere des linken Flügels bei den
Grünen und dieser Paus hat heute die
Gelegenheit genutzt Druck zu machen
vielleicht ihre letzte Gelegenheit denn
bis Ende August so hat es der
Bundeskanzler gefordert soll sie einen
gemeinsamen Entwurf vorlegen der von
allen Seiten mitgetragen wird Robert
Habeck hat das ganze heute nach unserem
Verständnis mitgetragen aus
Koalitionskreisen wurde uns bestätigt
dass er gemeinsam mit dem Bundeskanzler
vorgeschlagen hat dass
wachstumschancengesetz auch auf Ende
August zu verschieben und damit noch
einmal Zeit zu schaffen und man sieht
man sieht da dann auch dass beide in
Kauf nehmen zugunsten dieser
Streitigkeiten oder zugunsten von mehr
Zeit für die Lösung dieses Streites dass
der gemeinsame Neustart in der Ampel der
harmonisch vonstatten gehen sollte nach
der Sommerpause direkt mit dem nächsten
Streit verhandelt worden ist
danke schön für diese Einschätzung
cannabis ist bislang in Deutschland mit
wenigen Ausnahmen verboten doch die
Bundesregierung will das Rauschmittel
für Erwachsene kontrolliert in geringen
Mengen erlauben auch dazu hat das
Kabinett heute einen Gesetzentwurf
verabschiedet gegen erheblichen
Widerstand dazu gleich mehr zunächst
fast Volker Duce die Pläne zusammen
künftig soll der Besitz von 25 Gramm für
Menschen ab 18 straffrei sein erlaubt
wird der Anbau von drei Cannabispflanzen
für den eigenen Gebrauch wer mehr anbaut
oder besitzt dem drohen eine Geldstrafe
und eine Freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei
Jahren
frei verkauft werden darf Cannabis nicht
für die Abgabe sind sogenannte
Cannabis-Clubs zuständig diese Vereine
werden durch Behörden zugelassen und
haben viele Auflagen sie bauen die
handpflanzen an und geben Blüten oder
Harz an ihre Mitglieder ab kiffen ist in
den Clubs verboten noch nicht geklärt
ist wie Cannabiskonsum bei Autofahrern
kontrolliert werden soll das
Verkehrsministerium will klare Regeln
und Grenzwerte wie beim Alkohol
festlegen darum soll sich jetzt seine
Arbeitsgruppe kümmern
mit dieser Teil Legalisierung von
Cannabis will Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach die steigende
Drogenkriminalität zurückdrängen und
Risiken durch verschmutzte Drogen vom
Schwarzmarkt eindämmen doch kritik kommt
von verschiedenen Seiten den Einen geht
das Gesetz viel zu weit den anderen
nicht weit genug Christiane hübscher
noch dürfen Sie hier nur auf Rezept
Rauchen bald schon wollen sie den Stoff
als Verein auch offiziell anbauen und
verkaufen in Cannabis Social Club
Nürnberg gut dass das Kiffen bald legal
wird sagen sie hier hätten sich vom
Gesetz aber mehr erhofft jeder der über
25 Gramm braucht und jetzt nicht in
einem Cannabis Social Club ist findet
sich wieder im schwarzmarktbereich mit
wieder kriminalisiert eben jenen
illegalen Drogenhandel auszutrocknen ist
das erklärte Ziel von
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach er
verspricht heute die beste Form einer
versuchten Legalisierung das gesamte
Thema wird end tabuisiert und die
Tatsache dass jetzt z.B über diese
Schäden viel gesprochen wird wird ja
schon daher finde ich auch die
Diskussion um das Gesetz die ja
Kontroverse ist nicht schwierig sondern
hilfreich so sind Kinder und
jugendmediziner vehement gegen die
ampelpläne stoßen sich vor allem an der
Zulassung ab 18 die gehören wachsen bis
Jahre und sind noch in Entwicklung
begriffen und Cannabis ist da einfach
toxisch während sie sich hier bei der
Berliner handparade kurz vorm Ziel sehen
befürchten Polizei und Justiz neues
regulierungs-chaos so sollen zum
Beispiel mindestens 200 Meter zwischen
einem hanfanbauverein und einer Kita
liegen staatlichen Kontrollverlust
wittert auch die Union ich kann Ihnen
versichern das sächsische Polizeibeamte
nicht in der Lage sein werden
Abstandsregelungen zu Kindertagesstätten
oder Schuleinrichtungen 200 Meter
abzumessen ich kann Ihnen versichern
dass wir nicht in der Lage sein werden
zu zählen ob jeder Erwachsene nur drei
Hanfpflanzen zu Hause hat der
Gesundheitsminister will Cannabis
erlauben zeitgleich aber eine große
Aufklärungskampagne für Jugendliche
Staaten woher das Geld dafür kommen soll
ist noch ungeklärt
wie andere Länder den Konsum und Verkauf
regulieren das finden sie auf ZDF heute
und in unserer ZDF heute App dort gibt
es noch mehr Interessantes zum Thema
zusammengestellt von unseren Online
Kollegen zum Beispiel diese 3D Story die
erklärt woraus Cannabis besteht und wie
es im Körper wirkt
Datenklau Software die Firmen und
Behörden lahmlegt Hackerangriffe mit
denen Geld erpresst werden soll
Cyber-Attacken haben in Deutschland im
vergangenen Jahr 203 Milliarden Euro an
Schaden verursacht insgesamt waren es
mehr als
136.000 Angriffe so das
Bundeskriminalamt dies sei aber nur die
Spitze nicht erfasst seien die Angriffe
aus dem Ausland ohnehin geht die Polizei
davon aus dass etwa 90% aller
kriminellen Cyberangriffe nicht gemeldet
würden
die Krise bei den Linken verschärft sich
jetzt sieht auch Dietmar Bartsch sich
von der Fraktionsspitze zurück vor
anderthalb Wochen hatte bereits die
co-fraktionsvorsitzende Amira Mohammed
Ali angekündigt bei der nächsten
Vorstandswahl nicht mehr anzutreten
bartsch hat immer wieder vor einer
Spaltung der Linken gewarnt und
wagenknechts liebäugeln eine neue Partei
zu gründen kritisiert Andrea Maurer über
eine zerrissene linke
er war einer der immer versucht hat die
Linksfraktion über machtbündnisse
zusammenzuhalten viele haben ihn gebeten
Fraktionschef zu bleiben aber Dietmar
Bartsch will nicht mehr auch wenn seine
Partei gerade Gefahr läuft zu zerfallen
das ist eine Gefahr gibt es ist nicht
neu und das hat auch nichts mit meiner
Entscheidung zu tun wir sind in einer
ausgesprochen schwierigen Situation und
ich habe an dieser Stelle mehrfach
gesagt und wiederholt das gern dass es
nur einen Ausweg gibt und diese Ausweg
heißt Politik Politik und nochmals
Politik zuletzt gab es in der 4,9%
Partei vor allem eins Streit Streit und
nochmals Streit und Sarah Wagenknecht
Drogen eine neue Partei zu gründen erst
vor eineinhalb Wochen hatte die
co-fraktionschefin Amira Mohammed Ali
ihren Rückzug erklärt mit klarem
Bekenntnis zu Wagenknecht bekennt sich
heute zur Einheit der Partei die
Parteivorsitzenden stehen für Interviews
nicht zur Verfügung sie danken ihm
schriftlich
wir wissen dass wir mit ihm immer einen
Verbündeten haben im Kampf um eine
starke und geeinte linke
es geht nun um die Existenz der Linken
Bundestagsfraktion gründet Wagenknecht
eine neue Partei und verlassen mehr als
drei Abgeordnete die Fraktion verliert
sie ihren Status mit Dietmar Bartsch
zieht sich ein machtstratege Zurück
geschätzt über Parteigrenzen hinweg die
Frage ist nun wer will diese Fraktion
übernehmen die am Ende vielleicht bald
abgewickelt werden muss und wer kann sie
übernehmen für die Wahl zum
Fraktionsvorsitzenden braucht es 20 von
39 Stimmen in der zersplitterten
Fraktion sind solche
Mehrheitsverhältnisse kaum absehbar die
Wahl zur neuen Fraktionsspitze findet am
4 September statt
in die Ukraine nach Odessa dort ist
heute das Containerschiff einer
deutschen Reederei aus dem Hafen
ausgelaufen seit Beginn der russischen
Invasion im Februar letzten Jahres hatte
es festgesessen jetzt ist es das erste
Frachtschiff das den Hafen durch einen
von der Ukraine eingerichteten Korridor
verlässt
beschossen wurde in der Nacht ein
anderer ukrainischer Hafen Reni an der
Donau die russischen Drohnen
beschädigten Getreide sie los und
Lagerhäuser
wegen des Kriegs sind die diplomatischen
Beziehungen zwischen Deutschland und
Russland auf einem Tiefpunkt heute hat
der neue deutsche Botschafter in Moskau
seinen Posten angetreten der ehemalige
fdp-bundestags und Europaabgeordnete
Alexander graf-lamsdorf der 56-Jährige
wurde mit heftigen Vorwürfen begrüßt von
einem konfrontativen und unfreundlichen
Charakter der deutschen Politik sprach
das russische Außenministerium die
politische Lage sei enorm schwierig
sagte Lamsdorf im ZDF er hoffe dass
trotzdem ein professioneller Kontakt zur
russischen Regierung möglich sei
die USA sind uns technisch mit unter
einen Schritt voraus und so bietet San
Francisco einen Blick in die Zukunft die
kalifornische Stadt erlaubt nach einer
Testphase den unbegrenzten Einsatz von
Roboter Taxis allerdings sind die
fahrerlosen Autos umstritten sie seien
nicht sicher bemängeln Kritiker zudem
blockierten sie Busspuren und
Rettungseinsätze hat Details
wer ein robo-taxi ausprobiert kann
wirklich was erleben in diesem Fall
bleibt es einfach stehen Minuten lang
zieht dann ur plötzlich Richtung
Mittelstreifen blockiert die Spuren
nervt die anderen Verkehrsteilnehmer die
das aber gar nicht überrascht
aber ist das wirklich symptomatisch in
San Francisco läuft seit Jahren der
robotaxi-test fahrerlos chauffieren die
Firmen waymond Cruise Kameras und
Sensoren überwachen analysieren lenken
dass die Behörden robotaxis in San
Francisco nun rund um die Uhr zulassen
ruft Befürworter und Gegner auf den Plan
die Technik sei nicht ausgereift
es ist das bestgefahrene Auto in dem ich
Jesus sagt sie
Taxifahrer fürchten dass sie überflüssig
werden
tausende werden ihre Jobs verlieren im
Testgebiet wurden in den letzten fünf
Jahren mehrere hundert Zwischenfälle
registriert auch zusammen Stöße zum
Beispiel mit diesem Bus
bisher keine Todesopfer aber 64
verletzte meist blockieren sie nur den
Verkehr
unsere Fahrzeuge sind designt dass sie
bei unübersichtlichen Situationen
anhalten aber Sie sollten eigentlich
nichts blockieren
tatsächlich liegt die Unfallrate bei
robotaxis um ein Drittel niedriger als
bei herkömmlichen Autos ach und die
Panne bei der Probefahrt löst die
Betreiberfirma klassisch ein echter
Fahrer übernimmt
dieser Sommer bleibt wechselhaft gestern
Abend und in der Nacht gingen in Bayern
und im Osten Deutschlands schwere
Unwetter nieder im Erzgebirge
verursachten Hagel und Starkregen
Überschwemmungen in der Stadt
Brandenburg an der Havel wütete ein
Gewitter mit Orkanböen mit bis zu 148 km
je Stunde dabei wurden Dächer abgedeckt
zahlreiche Bäume stürzten um und es
bleibt unbeständig in der Nacht drohen
unwetterartige Gewitter
ja und in Australien ist gerade Stimmung
Norbert die Mathildas haben eher WM
Halbfinalspiel verloren ja aber mit
erhobenen Haupt über 70.000 Fans in
Sydney hatten ihr Team immer wieder
angepeitscht aber am Ende reichte es
nicht gegen die coolen Europameisterin
eins zu drei und so trifft England am
Sonntag im Finale auf Spanien
Australiens Fans aus allen finalträumen
gerissen zu stark zu abgeklärt die
Europameisterinnen aus England den
ersten Dämpfer verpassen Sie den
WM-Gastgeberinnen in der 36 Minute
Ella tune und widerstehlich nach dem
Wechsel lässt Sam coeur die
australischen Fans noch mal hoffen
erstmals nach Verletzungen in der Stadt
elf begeistert der Superstar der
Mathildas mit dieser Einzelleistung zum
eins zu eins
acht Minuten lang scheint nun alles
möglich doch dann bestraft Lauren Hamp
das zu zögerliche Eingreifen von
Elli Carpenter England wieder vorn für
den Endstand zum 3:1 sorgt in der 86
Minute Alessia Russo die
Europameisterinnen nach ihrer besten
Turnierleistung im Endspiel
[Applaus]
Union Berlin rüstet sich für seine
champions-league-premiere und hat Robin
Gossens verpflichtet der deutsche
Nationalspieler kommt für 15 Millionen
Euro Ablöse von Inter Mailand einen Tag
nach Verkündung des Transfer Kuh bekommt
der neu eiserne Robin großens ein
Vorgeschmack auf das Försterei Feeling
Union hat mir wirklich eine
Wertschätzung entgegengebracht die ich
bisher so persönlich im fußball-business
noch nicht wirklich miterlebt habe durch
den Wechsel von Inter Mailand erlangt
Robin großens auch mehr Aufmerksamkeit
für die Nationalmannschaft vor der Heime
em kommen des Jahr Bundesliga Premiere
für ihn in einem Team dass ich sicher
noch verstärken wird
die deutschen Rollstuhlbasketballer
haben bei den European para
Championships in Rotterdam den Einzug
ins Halbfinale geschafft in einem
packenden Duell bezwang sie Italien mit
69 zu 63
Jubel im deutschen Team fasst das ganze
Spiel über hatten die Italiener souverän
vorne gelegen erst durch diesen drei
Punkte Wurf von Alexander hallo Ski in
den letzten Sekunden des dritten
Viertels schaffen die deutschen erstmals
den Ausgleich in einem Kampf betonten
Match bei dem der Bundestrainer nie an
seiner Truppe gezweifelt hat wir glauben
dass wir wissen dass wir immer noch mal
zum Schluss zurückkommen können aber das
hat tatsächlich eine Weile gedauert bis
wir die richtige Taktik gefunden haben
als die Suche beendet ist flattern den
Italienern die Nerven das nutzen die
deutschen eiskalt aus ziehen durch
verlustiges Treffsicherheit mit sechs
Punkten davon und feiern den Einzug ins
Halbfinale dort geht es morgen gegen die
Vize Weltmeister aus Großbritannien
ja und jedenfalls gegen Großbritannien
spielen gleich die deutschen Rollstuhl
Basketballerinnen da geht sogar um den
Finale Anzug drücken ja immer danke
schön Norbert fehlen noch die
Lottozahlen sie lauten 4 5 14 19 26 41
Superzahl acht weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF
Text auf Seite 57
aktuell waren der Deutsche Wetterdienst
vor starker Hitze im Süden Deutschlands
und vor schweren Gewittern in Teilen
Baden-Württembergs mehr dazu hat gleich
Christoph
augeneck freut sich auf Sie im heute
journal um viertel vor zehn und wir
freuen uns wenn Sie morgen wieder dabei
sind einen schönen Abend noch und auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend so schwül wie im Moment
ist es in Deutschland nur selten das
bedeutet wir haben eine hohe Luftfeuchte
viel Energie die für schwere Gewitter
zur Verfügung steht regional sind ja
auch schon einige unterwegs die lassen
heute Nacht Drasch nach aber ebenfalls
heute Abend zieht aus Frankreich ein
gewitterkomplex in den Südwesten der es
in sich hat extrem heftiger Starkregen
Lokal sind bis zu 100 Liter pro
Quadratmeter möglich zusammen mit
schweren Sturmböen und Hagel und das
ganze kommt im Verlauf der Nacht in etwa
bis nach Sachsen-Anhalt voran verfolgen
Sie also auf jeden Fall die Warnungen
des Deutschen Wetterdienstes die
Temperaturen sinken dazu auf 19 bis 11
Grad ganz im Norden generell im
Nordwesten ja eine weniger warme und
auch trockenere Luftmasse im Moment da
gibt es auch morgen so 20 bis 23 Grad
sonst 23 bis 26 im Süden dann 27 bis 31
Grad am Oberrhein dazu schon am
Vormittag noch dieser gewitterkomplex
der weiter in Richtung Mecklenburg
Superman zieht erst auch noch stark
Regen möglich im Nordwesten ruhiger wie
schon die ganzen letzten Tage im Süden
am Vormittag noch viel Sonne nachmittags
schwächt sich das Ganze im Nordosten ab
im Süden entstehen entstehen aber neue
Gewitter mit unwetterpotenzial auch in
den nächsten Tagen gibt es noch Gewitter
das werden aber viel weniger und dafür
erwartet den Süden eine ordentliche
Hitzewelle mit bis 35 Grad tschüss